it's been a little over two months since
the 20/20 MacBook Air was released and
since then we actually got the new
13-inch MacBook Pros as well and we
finally just finished doing a ton of
testing and comparison videos between
these laptops and we now know exactly
who should be buying the MacBook Air
instead of paying the extra cash for the
pro two months ago there was a ton of
hype over the MacBook Air for a couple
of different reasons they new magic
keyboard the tenth gentian and the lower
nine hundred and ninety nine dollar
price tag but other than that there
really weren't any other changes this
year so let's take a little deeper into
the magic keyboard we've been testing
this keyboard out for a while ever since
the 16 inch MacBook Pro and our final
conclusion is that it's so good that we
don't want Apple to change it just like
the MacBook Airs incredible force touch
trackpad which is pure perfection and we
wouldn't want Apple to change this
basically ever we also don't want Apple
to change the magic keyboard it's
literally that good you get the perfect
balance of both key travel and feedback
so what makes for really accurate and
comfortable typing for long sessions and
since it now feels more like a
traditional laptop keyboard it's easier
for Windows users to switch over but I'd
say that this new magic keyboard feels
better than a lot of Windows laptops
which was never the case before so great
job Apple but the most important thing
is Apple finally scrapping the previous
keyboards butterfly name which
temporarily destroyed the reputation of
Apple's MacBook lineup and for the past
six months since the release of this new
keyboard on the 16 inch pro we haven't
experienced any reliability issues at
all nor have we heard of any online so
this is great news for consumers now the
bad news for the case of the MacBook Air
is that this new keyboard is also
available on the new 13-inch MacBook Pro
as well and that MacBook also finally
gets a physical Escape key which was
probably the number one thing that
people hated about the touch bar on the
pro now before I get into our thoughts
the new 10th gen chip I want to talk
about the new price point what really
surprises this year is that Apple not
only dropped the price by $100 but they
also gave it double the storage as well
and that 256 gig storage upgrade used to
cost $200 so essentially this year's
MacBook Air is $300 cheaper than the
2019 model in terms of value and you're
getting the new magic keyboard and the
tension chip on top of that but perhaps
the craziest thing of all is that after
only two months you can now get this
MacBook Air on Amazon for only nine
hundred and fifty dollars brand-new
which is honestly a steal of a deal
compared to last year so if you guys are
interested we'll drop a link down to
that sale in the description below so
that brings us to the most important and
controversial feature surrounding this
MacBook Air and that's the new 10th
gentian when you look at the spec sheet
and compare it to the specs of the base
13-inch MacBook Pro the air honestly
looks better after all this is a tension
ship so it's got to perform better than
the old 8th gen ship and the pro right
and the RAM in this MacBook Air is rated
at 3733 megahertz compared to only 2133
on the pro and you can even pay just
$100 more and get a quad-core chip in
the air that should easily wipe the
floor with a pro rights well what we
found was the complete opposite every
single aspect of performance was worse
on the air and the reason for that is a
little flaw in the MacBook Airs design
but that little flaw was actually fatal
the MacBook Air has both a fan and a
heatsink covering the processor but
unfortunately the two aren't physically
connected using a heat pipe so the
cooling system is absolutely atrocious
now before I get into the horrible
cooling I want to just give you guys a
general idea of the raw performance
differences between the two
surprisingly in Geekbench 5 CPU test
even the i7 10 gen chip in the air was
weaker than the base I 5 chip in the pro
and that's
performance without accounting for
cooling now the bonus for the air is
that both of the quad-core chips feature
Intel's new g7 graphics so they actually
have much more raw graphics performance
compared to the base macbook pro so we
then tested Unigine seven gaming
benchmark which mostly uses graphics
power so it would make sense for the air
to perform better
however right after we started the test
the MacBook Air shot up to a hundred
degrees Celsius yes that's Celsius not
Fahrenheit for those people who
commented thinking that we made a
mistake
in contrast the pro was at 91 degrees
Celsius at that part of the test and
then a couple minutes into the test both
laptops were basically maxing out their
fans but the difference was that the pro
cooled down to 83 degrees from 91 while
the air were still stuck at a hundred
degrees and because of that the MacBook
Air ended up scoring lower even though
the graphics power is much higher the
complete opposite of what the spec sheet
would make you believe in a different
test I connected our EGP you set up and
tried to play some games into Windows 10
but it didn't work out well at all the
gameplay was choppy and the frame rates
were pretty bad compared to the MacBook
Pro with the same each of you I
discovered that while I was playing with
the MacBook Air the CPU was literally at
a hundred degrees Celsius the entire
time bottlenecking the entire system and
the e GPU so the moral of the story is
that for anything graphics related you
should absolutely avoid the air but what
about just processor performance well
it's basically just as bad we tested
both the dual core and the quad core i5
model of the MacBook Air using the Sun
Oven chart 20 stress tests both models
of the air that we tested were at a
hundred degrees Celsius the entire time
so from this we know that the i7 model
would have done the exact same thing
since it uses even more power we ended
up with incredibly low scores compared
to the raw performance scores we got in
Geekbench 5 specifically the base
macbook pro was 21% faster than the i5
book air and Geekbench face multi-core
test but in the cinema jar 20 stress
test it was actually 63% faster and that
massive difference is all due to the
horrible cooling that's in the MacBook
Air we then also tested the SSDs on both
the MacBook Air and the Bass Pro and
even though they're the exact same 256
gig size the one on the pro was quite a
bit faster for both read and write
speeds now you might be thinking that's
fine I don't mind I don't really need
great performance on the air well the
issue is not just the lower performance
but the heat and fan noise issues as
well we tested out the quad core i5
MacBook Air model and we saw the temps
hit a hundred degrees Celsius and a lot
of common tasks like watching a 4k 60p
video downloading a game or even opening
up a bunch of tabs using Chrome this
should not be happening on a brand-new
laptop in 2020 and don't just take our
word for it
multiple commenters mention that the fan
on their MacBook Air was really loud
while doing basic tasks like video
conferencing using zoom and that's the
last thing that you want during a
meeting so basically after all of that
testing we settled on this conclusion if
you care about performance or fan noise
whatsoever like at all just buy the bass
MacBook Pro instead so the final
question is who should be buying the
20/20 MacBook Air well there are a
couple of user groups who the air
actually makes sense for the first group
are those who want the cheapest possible
brand new MacBook and at only 950
dollars using the link below it's
definitely a killer deal now the second
group is for those who need a premium
laptop for doing a lot of typing whether
it's for school or for your job typing
on this portable MacBook is great and
finally the third group is for those who
do a lot of basic web browsing like
surfing the web using social media
watching Netflix or YouTube or doing
business related work using Google Drive
QuickBooks or building your website for
the
three groups the base 2020 MacBook Air
is an excellent choice
since you're saving 350 dollars compared
to the base MacBook Pro and for users
who like to have a lot of chrome tabs
open the 16 gigabyte RAM upgrade will
make a lot of sense especially if you
want to use it long term so if you want
to learn more about that base 2020
MacBook Pro you can check out our review
of that laptop right over there and if
you enjoyed this review you can click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]